britney spears's lawyer claims her dad
jamie spears is trying to extort
millions to step down as conservator of
her estate after 13 years of the status
quo
my firm and i would move aggressively
and expeditiously
to file a petition to suspend
and remove james p spears
we look forward to litigating the matter
in court in new docks obtained by e.t
britt's attorney matthew rosengart
alleges that jaime is seeking 2 million
dollars in payments
that includes 1.3 million dollars in
attorney's fees
500 000 to britney's former management
company and additional payments to jamie
himself e.t has reached out to jamie for
comment
[Music]
inside the docs filed by rosengart he
writes quote mr spears's blatant attempt
to barter suspension and removal in
exchange for approximately two million
dollars in payments on top of the
millions already reaped from ms spears's
estate by mr spears and his associates
is a non-starter he goes on to defend
britney insisting she will not be quote
bullied or extorted by her father and
says jaime does not have the right to
try to hold his daughter hostage by
setting the terms of his removal brit's
attorney is also asking the court for
the suspension and removal of jamie as
soon as possible something the 69 year
old louisiana native agreed to do last
month but only when the time is right
jamie also noted at the time that he'll
work with the court on an orderly
transition this is just a groundbreaking
day et spoke with legal expert rachel
stockman shortly after jaime announced
his decision to step down what he's
saying in what he just filed in court is
that he is willing to step down in the
best interests of britney spears however
he wants to talk to all the parties and
he wants to get a plan in place to make
sure it's done in a what he calls
respectable way that's good for britney
spears while rosengart praised jaime's
willingness to step down and brittany's
mom lynn spears told et in a statement
that she is pleased by jamie's decision
stockman says the spears family is
ultimately going to have to come
together what jamie spears is asking in
terms of next steps is for all of the
interested parties uh involved in this
britney spears attorney lin spears to
get together and kind of have a
discussion in terms of what the next
step should be